Speaker 1: Okay. We have a voicemail number.
That number is 2192. David P Here's a really
good question about our colleague Luke Beasley,
who has been going to Trump rallies recently.
Speaker 2: Hey, David, I actually have.
Speaker 4: A question for you
and friend of the show.
Speaker 1: Beasley Yeah.
Speaker 3: Does he ever feel
unsafe at these rallies? Because,
you know, you played that clip where that guy
was just cursing a lot and, you know, Democrats.
Speaker 4: Yep. What are these people
ever done for Americans?
Speaker 3: And then Luke.
Speaker 4: Named a couple of things
to try to get a few words in there.
And, you know, when people are that unhinged.
Speaker 3: I don't try to talk to them. And
it's not that I don't want to. I love it. I love
his videos. I love, you know, what he says. It
was great. Um, I just wonder, you know.
Speaker 4: Does he ever feel unsafe?
Speaker 1: Yeah, this is a fair question. And, you
know, Luke is becoming more recognizable because
he's been going to these rallies for a while.
So I think I plan to have a conversation with
Luke to ask about that because we want the number
one priority is for Luke to be safe. And we we're
certainly conscious of that, no doubt about it.
We have a great bonus show for you today. We will
talk about Nancy Pelosi saying her retirement will
be affected by the attack on her husband. We will
talk about Facebook's plan to lay off thousands
as it has trouble in paradise. And we will talk
about Nike suspending its relationship with Kyrie
Irving over his anti-Semitic post. All of those
stories and more on today's bonus show.
Speaker 2: Oh, the bonus show where you
want to make money. Everybody else who
makes money to fund themselves is bad.
Speaker 1: See it for yourself. Don't take
Alex Jones word for it. Sign up at join.